one of the things psychologists have
done for the last 20 years especially
the social psychologist has pushed this
idea of self-esteem you should feel good
about yourself and I think why would you
tell someone 20 that it's like you
should feel good about who you are it's
like no you shouldn't why should you
feel good about who you are it's like
you should feel good about who you could
be that's way better cuz you got 60
years to turn into who you could wait a
minute are you what your accomplishments
are or are you dis individual going
through this journey I mean I don't
think there's anything wrong with
feeling good about who you are as long
as it's tempered by an understanding of
potential and what you have accomplished
versus what you can accomplish well I
think having confidence is a big part it
is it is I'm not saying that people
shouldn't have confidence but like often
you take young people say there are 16
to 22 and they're not really feeling
that good about who they are right
because their life is chaotic and and
disorder and they don't know where
they're going and that they don't know
which way is up a call so there could be
bad parenting and I think that's one of
the reasons why people that resonates
with people this idea of be happy for
you about who you are right feel good
about who you write but but the thing is
it has to be stated with precision it's
like yes it's like you should you should
treat yourself as if you're valuable
especially in the potential but you
should concentrate on who you should
become especially if you're young and so
let's say you're miserable and
nihilistic and chaotic and depressed and
all of that now and you have your
reasons you know terrible parenting
abuse all of those things it's like well
you should feel good about yourself it's
like no no it's not it's not the right
message is that it's more like you
should understand how much potential
there is within you to set that straight
and then you should do everything you
can to manifest that in the world and it
will set it straight and that's better
than self esteem it's like you're you're
in a crooked horrible position okay fine
there's a lot of suffering and pain
associated with that yeah you can't just
feel good about that because it's not
good but you can do something about it
you can genuinely do something about it
and I think all the evidence suggests
that that's the case yes so I'm telling
telling young people look there's no
matter how bad your situation is I'm not
gonna pretend it's okay it's not okay
it's tragic
tainted with malevolence and some
we'll really get hurt by malevolent
people like you know terribly hurt
sometimes they never recover it's really
awful but there's more to you than you
think and if you stand up and face it
with with the positive with a with a
noble vision with discipline and intent
you can go far farther to overcoming it
than you can imagine and that's the
principle upon which you should
predicate your behavior and I think that
one of the things that's really nice
about being the clinical psychologist is
that this isn't just guesswork like one
of the things we know two things in
clinical psychology one is truthful
conversations redeemed people because if
you come to a clinical psychologist
whose Worth is salt you'll have a
truthful conversation the conversation
is well here's what's wrong with my life
and here's what caused it you know maybe
it takes a year to have that
conversation and both of the
participants are doing everything they
can to lay it out properly here's how it
might be fixed here's what a beneficial
future might look like and so it's a
completely honest conversation if it's
working well and all that's happening in
the conversation is that the two people
involved are trying to make things
better that's the goal let's see if we
can have a conversation that will make
things better okay so we know that works
it does make things better and then
another thing we know is that well let's
say there's a bunch of things that
you're afraid of that are in your way so
you have some vision about who you want
to be maybe you have to you know you
want to be successful in your career so
you have to learn to talk in front of a
group it's like okay well you're afraid
of that no wonder you don't want to be
humiliated so okay so what do we do
about that
well maybe we first get you to speak in
front of one person and then three
people you know for five minutes and
then for ten minutes like graduated
exposure to what you're afraid of
voluntary graduated exposure to what
you're afraid of is curative and that's
true
it works the documentation is in it's
how people learn so so to to to tell
people that if you confront the world
forthrightly if you speak the truth and
you expose yourself courageously to
those things that you're afraid of that
your life will improve and so will the
life of people around you like as far as
I'm concerned that's as close to
undeniable fact as we as we've got and
it also dovetails nicely with the under
law
typical stories the heroic stories it's
like go out there find the dragon
confront it
it's a dragon it might eat you it's
dangerous but it's worse to cower at
home and wait for it to come and devour
you go out there confront it get the
gold
share it with the community it's like
yeah it's the oldest story of mankind